it seems like coming from poland
coming from not having food from being
in prison from all these things that are
going on
it seems like when you get to america
you've just got this
this like drive just to live and make
things happen and you're going a free
fall and you get it done in four days
and then i'm gonna become a jump master
and you're working as hard as you can
it's like you have this open freeway in
front of you
you can be whatever you are able to be
you know i can't say whatever you want
to be
because i want to be astronomer i'm 60
years old i ain't going to be asking
about that with me but
but but you can be whatever you are able
to be there is nothing to stop you like
different countries
what's your background who is your mom
did you do
are you communist or are you belong to
socialist party so we can help you but
if you know that you cannot be
in these positions you cannot go to to
college even if you don't have
you are not part of the socialist youth
organization
so so for me yeah it was like the entire
world open i could be whatever i was
able to be
and there was nothing stopping me so
even more
even more makes me uh that
stick to my word i want to be the best
citizens i want to make this country the
best it can be
and and contribute to it so that's where
the first
person work him out and i just became
u.s citizen at the time
so i was like okay
i can't build the jobs for these people
i'm not rich enough i don't have
resources
but i can fight for them so this is my
country i'm going to go and
sign up i had no idea how to do it i
remember in post office i seen those
draft cards sometimes that you you fill
it up so i say
i went up there i filled it up i sent it
out i packed my [ __ ] i was living with
other skydivers at the time
so they said what was going on where are
you going i said i'm going to war
i just sent out my papers and this is
this is the first
gulf war right so it's 1991
yes the first gulf war kicks off yes you
want to go fight i don't so you go down
to the post office
grab the uh what's that thing called the
the selective service
[Music]
so well nothing happens the guy's like
drago you know i don't think that's the
right way to do it
but
man there's a war going on up there i
say yeah yeah i mean
you have to help this i came here with
nothing
and everything i have i altered america
to this country
i need to do something and the best way
i can do is going to fight for my
country
so yeah that's uh i'm waiting on the
vendor simulator
sorry but this selective service doesn't
apply to you you're too old
so i was already 31 at the time going 32
and so i say
i find my i will find my way into that
war
so somebody said hey why don't you go to
recruiting of recruiting office
as a sure i went to the uh
army for in poland army is everything
yes this is like army are you talking
about army air forces
for me at that time was everything was
army so good to army say
okay this is me i would like to join
military i would like to go to war
it's like okay what do you want to do or
say
a fight there's like no no like a jobs
or something you have any skills
i say no not really but
i would doubt do whatever you tell me to
do you know i just want to go to war
hour when the war is over i will go back
to my normal life but i
i think just for the duration of the war
i would like to join the military
they say okay well let me see that look
at my documents
they tell me what to bring so i bring
all that stuff they did all the
all the work say so okay so we put you
as a infantryman i think it was infantry
man and stuff and
i say absolutely thank you so much i'm
ready to go anytime
and then as seals show up
in our drop zone they were doing
demonstration jump uh leapfrogs
in uh in memphis so we started talking
about it
we jump few times together and said
they're such a cool guys
you know and uh so they um yeah
it's like but you know before they join
the army why don't you try the navy
just go and ask recruiters about seals
i was like seals what's the seals yeah
but the navy
these cool guys knows i'm jumping they
call themselves seals so i'll just go
and ask hey
i went the next door i said like i'm
applying here for army
and they have all my paperwork but i met
some friends who told me to ask about
the navy and the
i'm just asking about the navy who those
friends are so like they're current
themselves seals
oh yeah yeah you know you can be a ceo
it's like but you need to get those
paperwork from these guys we put you in
the navy
and you're okay then then we'll just put
you in the navy
you will be a seal then i say okay so i
went down next door
hey everybody i'm going there so can i
have it
they were pissed they did not like it
but so anyway i got my paperwork i show
up up there and they look through my
papers
and they're like eventually well you
know what we can guarantee you the seal
the dice there was a different program
at the time that we cannot guarantee to
you because you are way too old
you are even too old to qualify for the
sales but if you sign this paper here
you join you go to bootcamp that will
make you a zero that's not no doubt
about it
oh yeah so i said sure you know that's
enough
i say okay but they said but now before
you become a ceo
you need to get a job you have to select
the job in the navy at that time there
was no cl rating you remember that there
was a
you you go to bootcamp you get the eight
uh go to a school get the job in the
navy and then
you go to if you like you you are
assigned to go to seal training
so i said well i don't know much what i
want to do i'm parachuting something
with
how about being parachute regular cause
it sounds good to me
i have no idea what it was it stuck me
in this field for like as a e5 for years
later but
i said like okay so yeah absolutely yeah
make me serious and make me a
at that time i was dating a girl too so
they say okay but if you want to go to
that school to pr school
you will have to leave this week you
will have to leave on a
thursday we'll put you in the delay
entry program
and i think you'll be sworn on thursday
you will leave on friday i believe
that's i think it was like
sure notice so i call my girlfriend hey
we need to get murdered right now
because
i'm going to the navy i'm just like what
i said i'm leaving to the navy i'm
leaving this for this weekend
so we went to the judge we got like the
stand we got married very quick and uh
then i show up on the debt got sworn in
and
thursday i left to boot camp and didn't
become
that there was like no intention to make
me a ceo but you know for that time i
didn't really care
i just wanted to join military i want to
contribute to the effort
i am american i want to fight for my
country
so whether being the parachute trigger
whatever i just made the best out of it
but it says the opportunity shows up i
say why not to be a seal now i want
i try it and i did i passed all the
tests so that was
in boot camp and both they do that they
do that day where they go okay if you
want to try for seals you need to go
take the test right now yeah there is a
there is like a day that
actually there are different jobs i
think there's people that are coming and
telling about their jobs
so there are sales eod motivators show
up and he talked about i just couldn't
sit in this
[ __ ] chat just get out just hey yeah
yeah i want to go um so
and now you're are you 32 years old
at this point at this point 32 years old
i think what the f what the hell kind of
physical conditioning did you do
throughout your life to get to
get there and be in like good enough
shape because they don't even let guys
go to buds when they're
27 or 28 or something i don't know i
guess i gotta beat up a lot
i just got conditioned did you did you
work were you working out this whole
time
not really i didn't know how i didn't
know that the physical
uh demands of the seal teams at the time
are just like
they just in life what about just in
life like in
like when you were when you were working
in that freaking song
boxing taekwondo yeah that's that's that
was just basically what dude you're a
mutant
you're a freaking mutant uh well i just
can't consider myself
like that you know i was able to and you
know the test is really not that
difficult to pass yeah there is still
it's still something but
yeah preparing fail but yeah so so so
just so people know what you're talking
about you say the test
isn't that hard to pass the bait the
seal test that we used to get
to get a chance to go to seal training
was like i think it was you had to do
it's some minuscule it's like 50
push-ups
in two minutes 50 sit-ups in two minutes
yeah
eleven eight pull-ups ten pull-ups
eleven eleven pull-ups
and then a mile and a half run in a
11-30 and a mile
and a 500-yard swim or something like
that my struggle was with the swim which
i couldn't swim very well so
uh but i took it i got it you know
i passed it so i'm so happy i'm like oh
yeah this is so cool
and then i [ __ ] got the kidney stone
a kidney stone yeah well that's right
because you're a freaking old man
yeah yeah yeah so the kidney stone and
and i remember they that was so
freaking painful i mean i never wasn't i
was never beat up so hard that was so
painful
like this but uh that was so painful
that i remember they gave me that
medicine
i think it was demoral it's like didn't
work at all i said i need something
stronger because
i i just i'm i'm i'm about to go crazy
i'm
okay that pain is so so hot so they give
me a morphine
just like one away but i remember this
funny thing because the first time in
this room i had no idea what it was i
was lying in the bunk
in the boot camp and that's just this
pain came in i just fell off the bed
and so they turned the lights on and
within like three minutes i had this
pool of sweat right under my nose all
dripping i'm on my force
this medic comes hey are you okay it's
like [ __ ] do i look a cave to you
can't move so they got me the hospital i
passed that but
that was not the worst thing there was
things they told me well you know you're
going through this medical thing we're
about to give you the medical
examination for seals but you have just
had a kidney stone you have to wait the
air
it's like [ __ ] but you know my mindset
was
i want to fight the war in any capacity
you know i'm
i'm honored that i have that privilege
to go and fight for america
so for me this really matters so i said
that's that's okay
and so then i went to a school and the a
school i met
uh resident peace uh blessed barrios
i don't know if you knew him but so les
barrios uh
he was a motivator in millington when i
was going to the my parachuting school i
said look
i passed the test um i think i can
easily pass it again
but i had this kidney stone and i cannot
i just want to be a seal so
there's any way maybe there's some maybe
paperwork can be done
we just say a paperwork yeah i think you
can just go get your medical record from
your
uh from your medical office bring it
here we'll take a look at it
so i ran up there and said what magic he
will come up with i'm sure there's some
paragraph or some regulation that will
allow bypass the stupid kidney stone
so i brought this record and said that's
right
right there right there and it's like
okay i just i want you to leave the room
here i'll be
i'll just call you in a second and i
could hear rip
so he comes back so the kidney stone uh
where is that i was like right oh
so he likes i don't see any
i said i don't see any either you sure
he had the kidney stone
it's like you know maybe not
maybe i didn't okay well you didn't so
and i graduated uh from a school in
millington i think won the second top
you know everything that from bootcamp i
graduated top recruit in this whole
batch i was there
i got a military excellence award i was
like the first very first recruit
actually uh that who the top recruit
from that badge
graduating high school i graduated the
second
with the second highest score so i i had
things going on for me and then i was
waiting for
my orders he said okay i send it out for
it hopefully it gets approved
and sure three months later got my
orders too bad
so that that's the rest of this rest of
it is the history
you show up at buds what was uh
what was there any major challenges for
you was like you said you were not
not a great swimmer how were you on the
rest of the water stuff well the
the the the problem was that i could
swim only on one side and i never swim
with the mask on
so you know they dump in the pool and
say i want you to swim here there's a
side stroke
side stroke this is how you do it and
but you'll be swimming all the styles
that will tell you to do
it and i was kind of okay with it but
when they push them put the mask on
after the first couple laps i thought
i'll pass out i mean i was like
hyperventilating i was blacking out
i see the black spots in front of myself
i'm about to die here
but that's like if i stop they kick me
out so i ain't stopping i see i know
that
if i pass out they will rescue me that's
those guys everywhere they tell us that
we are safe so we are safe
so you know i was blacking out like who
fell about to black out having these
black spots but become easier
and easier but i think by the time like
the next hour i was like
[ __ ] they ain't that bad so what is it
just like some weird like claustrophobic
thing on your face or something like
that
no it couldn't breathe to my nose and i
couldn't breathe now how to breathe
through my every time i to get breath
i've sucked
water with it so i think i i i was
breathing water and air at the time and
i was coughing i was
suffocating i was i was basically
drowning i feel like i'm driving
and uh it's just i say i'm not going to
quit but i'll just
pass out and see what will happen if i
have to but um i didn't pass out and
i got better actually by the time there
was a fourth phase there was a preface
when
before you close up for the for the
serial training
so by the time we graduate from the
fourth phase move into our
single class the instructors asked me to
demonstrate the new guys how to swim the
side stroke so
i became really good i was never a fat
swimmer but i was strong swimmer i could
swim forever and you didn't you didn't
come up with any injuries or anything
being a 33 year old guy going through
buds
uh not at that time the the worst thing
is always tired i was looking at this
young guys
like hey let's go to the bar it was like
dude i can hardly move i can't go to the
bar
i'll still make it out to the bar here
and there but there was just like
really painful for me because uh again i
was not the intensity of it it's not
just the one time
because like one time like the seal
training i think most of the people that
one day can check out
he may survive but it over and over and
over it just wears your body wears you
down
and eventually some people quit so that
was the most difficult for me because uh
i'm did not recover as fast being 32
years old
as uh as other guys so what was your
first
were your first orders what team did you
get i get to see
your team two and uh actually they they
uh i wanted to go to sierra team four
because they i don't want to be called i
know cl2 at them
at the time operate the the north part
and the of the europe and
in europe in general so i say i just
want to go to like team four but friend
of mine says like no no dude
you with your language with your police
russian and you
i speak japanese too so uh with with
your languages
you'll be good asset in this european
team and stuff
so i kind of like put the switched it
from the
team four to team two and put in four
seconds and just like god please
don't put me in sdvs uh
i just for some reason i don't know i
was i was not maybe that technical
person at the time
and the challenge is to be as the
operator is twice as it is twice
it's got to be a seal but you have to
have that expertise
with this mini subs and with the the
operation of it
that for me i felt was overwhelmed by
that what you need to know to be good
operator in the sdv teams
so um so i i chose two and i got my
orders to cl team too
went to boot uh went to jam school uh
did you did you go to fort benning yes
for me it was kind of fun time because
uh you know like when i was
growing up i was poor i never had a
chance to go to like a disneyland or
this type of thing i could watch over
the fence how children were playing
around it but
i couldn't afford it so when i got into
this tower i was like holy [ __ ] this is
like a disneyland you know
so i didn't care what the position they
wanted me to jump but i just like
running out of it
and yeah that's uh they kind of didn't
like it but they
uh but they are very rigid so i remember
through those that i had a lot of fun
too because that was
i think you went through the same thing
yeah so there is uh the
fort benning so you still next to each
other shoulder shoulders so close
that basically you just cannot even move
and then you just go to your line you
grab the line they drag you just
do the p alive i could never do that plf
right i was always scared of plfs
so uh but anyway i found out that if you
like tip one of them from one end
it's like a domino effect they would
just totally fall down they would save
them
and that was actually i thought it was
it was amusing
it's like that's pretty cool you know
you tip one a little bit and the last
guy just
plops down um but my issue was that
uh i don't like prfs so
so just so everyone knows a plf is a
parachute landing fall
and it's a technique that you get taught
for static line jumping
where it's supposed to minimize your
injuries
because you keep your feet and knees
together and you
hit like you kind of like roll you sort
of roll
when you hit and you keep your arms kind
of tucked in
and it's supposed to prevent you from
getting injured because when you're on a
when you're on one of those parachutes
you're still coming down really fast
it's not like what you see in the movies
when guys can kind of come down on a
free-fall parachute and they flare and
they just kind of kind of tiptoe away
from it
you hit pretty hard especially if you're
a heavier guy the heavier you are the
harder you're going to hit
so they try and teach and plus the
army's working with
hundreds and hundreds of people getting
thrown out of that thing getting thrown
out of an aircraft every day
so they try and teach the most simple
way that they can teach
hundreds and hundreds of of people how
to fall without getting hurt
now i also was not good at the plf
yeah screw the [ __ ] out of me so i tried
one time and just popped my shoulder and
i like
[ __ ] doing it anymore so every time i
jump i just stood up i just i
it was not a big deal because i heard
hundreds of giants at the time so
i just jumped out just really landed
just stand up and i was like
so there's like there's they had those
those black black hats they had those
tubes plf private pli fpl if i want to
see ply i was like
roger dead and this jacket i might throw
my parachute and just roll on the ground
you know they don't hurt i didn't want
to come over
so so that they they knew from me from
not listening too good
yeah those plrs they were killing me so
i didn't do them
i avoided them